-You look fantastic.
Thank you for coming
on to the show.
-Thank you.
-I appreciate this.
I think the last time I saw you,
you were with your dad.
Your dad was on our show.
-Yes, and that was a
very embarrassing day for me.
-Why was that embarrassing?
-Well, I had just gotten off
the flight to see my dad
and I came here and I,
like, looked disgusting.
And I was just, kind of hiding
in the dressing room,
and my dad's friend was like,
"Oh, do you want to go upstairs
and, like, check out
the 'SNL' floor?"
And I was like, "Sure.
Like, hope I don't run into
anyone, whatever."
Harry Styles was hosting,
and I knew that, but I --
I was like, "There's no way I'm
going to see him, right?"
And then, the first thing --
Like, I walked into the room,
and he was right there.
And I literally,
like, could not --
Like, I went into shock.
Like, I didn't even know what to
do with myself.
And then I --
Yeah, I just went into a panic
and then I got back down to
the dressing room
and started hysterically crying
because I was so overwhelmed
and just not expecting that.
And then you
knocked on the door.
And I was so humiliated
and I hear like,
"Hey, Judd, it's Jimmy."
And I was like,
"Oh, no, no, no!"
And then I -- Yeah, so, then I
just turned and faced the wall,
like, thinking, like,
maybe if I turn around,
you won't notice I was there.
But the room was really small.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah, and then
you saw that I was crying.
And I was really humiliated by
that for like -- And I still am.
Like, telling it, I'm like,
"Why am I telling this?"
-Oh, no, I didn't -- That's
normally the reaction I get
when I say "hi"
to people backstage.
You weren't crying tonight,
I will say that.
Backstage, you were not crying.
But why were you nervous
for Harry?
Just -- Didn't you interview him
or interview One Direction?
-Yeah, I did interview
One Direction when I was 14.
-Now, what was this -- How did
you get a chance to do that?
-I don't even --
I had a popular Twitter page
when I was like 13.
-Uh-huh.
-And I decided I wanted
to become a child journalist,
and they asked me
to interview One Direction
on their first trip to America.
-Wow! And so that must be
nerve-racking.
-Yeah, it was, like,
the scariest thing in my life.
-Yeah, and I know that you were
freaking out before you --
right before you were
going to interview them.
And you were -- You were upset,
but your dad videotaped you.
-Yeah.
-Well, we talked to your dad.
And we have a video.
If you don't mind us
showing this,
this is 14-year-old Maude Apatow
preparing to interview
One Direction.
Here we go.
-Ooh!
-In 10 minutes, you'll be in the
room with One Direction.
Let's go!
-What is that?
-I couldn't even say words.
Like, they're just --
They weren't coming out.
-We have a picture of you, too,
minutes before
you were interviewing them.
Look at you.
You're so emotional.
I mean...
[ Cymbal crash ]
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, that was you.
But then this is you actually
interviewing the boys,
and you did a great job.
-I don't know if I did such a
great job, honestly.
-Oh, really? Was it bad?
-I don't think--
It couldn't have been good.
-Would you ever listen to it
again or play it back?
-No.
-No, of course not.
No, no, no.
-God no. No, no, no.
-Well, shortly after that,
you got to see One Direction
in concert.
Your dad told us this.
-I did, yes.
-And that must have been fun.
It probably went -- You probably
weren't nervous then?
-No. It was worse then.
-So, we have a video of you
right after the concert.
So, you saw the concert.
You had a great time.
-Yeah.
-And then,
this is after the concert
with your family
and your sister.
And here's -- Yeah, take a look.
-[ Crying ]
-Maude, you're fine.
-"Maude, you're fine."
-Oh, my God.
-You have good parents
to send that video to us,
so thank you to --
We appreciate that.
How is the family?
Everyone good?
-Yeah, everyone's great.
-Alright. We're fans.
Please say "hi"
to everyone over there.
I want to talk about "Euphoria."
This is a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...massive, massive, massive hit
on HBO this season.
Bigger than anything
in the world.
And everyone was
talking about it, like,
broke ratings records,
all this stuff.
But it's more finding
the backstories
of a lot of
the characters on this one.
Now, what can we expect for your
character, for Lexi?
-I think you'll see a lot more
of my character this season.
I don't know if
I can even say anything.
I'm going to get in trouble.
-Yeah, I know.
-But it's all exciting,
and I think people
are going to be surprised.
I think, like, people think
my character is sort of
this shy, like, sweet one,
but I think she might be
just as crazy as everyone else.
-Oh, my gosh. No, you're --
-No, she's not.
-Alright.
I don't know
if I can handle that.
You were telling me,
though, backstage
that every shot is
very technical on that show.
-It is very technical.
So, they'll, like,
do these long shots
where they don't make any edits,
so they'll have us, like,
walking through
the school hallways,
and it will be like
two minutes without any cuts.
So if you mess up,
the whole shot is destroyed,
and I always mess it up.
So then, yeah, basically --
-So if you mess up,
everyone has to redo the --
-And it became,
like, a running joke
that I would always
miss my mark.
Because they put,
like, a tiny, little piece
of tape on the ground.
And you can't look at it,
because then it's obvious
you're trying to find it.
-Yeah, that is true.
So you just have to,
like, zone and find the mark,
and you'll be like -- So,
they'll do the tracking shot,
and then you got to be like...
"Hey --" You know, whatever.
-Exactly!
-And they're like,
"No, over here."
And you go, "Oh, yeah."
"Hey!"
-I'm always like
10 inches off of the mark.
-Just a little bit off.
-But then they were like --
They started putting, like,
sandbags and boxes so I would
just, like, knock into it.
-You have to walk into a wall
to hit your mark?
-Yeah, it still didn't work.
-Yeah, I had one line in
"Band of Brothers,"
this miniseries on HBO.
And Tom Hanks was directing.
And I had to drive
a World War II Jeep
and then say like, "Hey, boys,
I'm getting the ammo"
or something.
And I go, "Great, let's do it."
And they go, "Oh, we got to wait
for it be nighttime."
I go, "Nighttime?"
And then he goes,
"We got to get the extras."
And they had 200 extras.
I had to drive through all
of these soldiers
trying to find my mark, where
I'm driving a car to my mark
and then say,
"I'm bringing ammo."
And I was maybe
like a mile off the mark.
So I drove in
and then just parked.
I go, "We got ammo, boys!
We got it."
And then Tom was way over there.
I was like,
"Where is everybody?"
He was like, "Dude,
you're way off the mark, buddy.
Can we replace him right now?
He's so bad."
But you were phenomenal in this,
and everyone is buzzing
and talking about you.
Congratulations
on all the success.
-Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Maude Apatow
in "Euphoria."
Take a look.
-How you doing?
-I'm good. Um...
-Hi.
I'm Faye.
-I'm Lexi. Um...
Are -- are you guys --
-Yeah, no, she's just staying
with me for a bit,
but -- but she's cool though.
What brings you out here anyway?
-Oh, I just came to get
a-a drink.
-Okay, well,
we got plenty of those.
Uh, do you need help
finding anything?
-No, I'm okay.
-Oh, uh, that's the malt liquor.
-Yeah, I know.
-What?!
Maude Apatow, everybody!
"Euphoria" airs Sundays at
9:00 p.m. on HBO and HBO Max.